may 13 2014 the stat 8 orbits above the
Colorado River in Utah it captures an
image of two large blue shapes shining
brightly in the desert you don't expect
to see such a vibrant blue color in the
middle of a brown desert the baffling
image is taken 25 miles west of the
desert town of Moab closer analysis
reveals patches of other bright colors
within the expanse of blue the blue
patches are too far out in the desert to
be anything intended for use by the
general public a more likely possibility
is that it's some kind of industrial
operation are we looking at some kind of
mining or drilling operation geological
records reveal this area contains large
reserves of a chemical known as potash
potash is a salt that occurs beneath
their surface it contains a lot of
potassium and we mined it for use and
fertilizer there are mines in this area
and the mining method that they are
using involves the construction of large
ponds in order to extract the potash the
miners drill down and pump water deep
underground
and we drill another hole it to a deeper
level and the water that's introduced to
the potash will flow through there
dissolve some of the potash be pumped up
to the surface but potash extraction
doesn't explain the vivid blue color
visible in the image potash is usually
red or white why is this blue the
startling colors are produced by the
addition of a dye to the evaporation
ponds deep blue color Sorbs the heat
faster so it evaporates faster adding
blue dye to an evaporation pond is a
highly unusual method for processing
potash not practiced anywhere else in
the world
you